Cats.
Pies.
Cats eat pies.
How we are supposed to actually pick up all this great content
Without great support for your camera during your apps?
I am David East, and uses API Camera 2
To build the best in the camera applications industry.
Let's take a step back to look at the history of options
Camera API in Android.
It has always been the simplest option for taking pictures
Videos, is the Intent camera.
This Intent is primarily launched
The user starts using the camera application
Who prefers to take a photo
Although easy to use but not
Suitable for large camera applications.
The Intent camera is suitable for applications where
The camera is attached
More than being a basic property, this is
It does not help us show the cat eating pancakes;
So we need a better API.
The API camera provided us with much greater control
From the Intent camera.
With the camera API you can build a view
Whatever camera you like, the camera API was great.
But as the photos progressed, it was definitely there
Some missing objects, for example no support
To capture uncompressed images.
Performance during the latest equipment, where it will be
Maximum viewing rate is one to three frames per second.
As it seems clear, our cat deserves a better API.
This API is a 2 camera.
API Camera 2 is the newest, largest, and coolest
In the group.
It provides you with perfect control
In your device's cameras,
It fixes all the problems we encountered with the old API.
Capture photos at faster intervals, and show shows
From most of the camera, and even add effects
directly.
But before you use your new camera application
There are some things you should learn.
Just because the API 2 camera is full
With great characteristics, that does not mean
All your users' devices will support it.
So you need to know the possibilities of each device,
You can find out
By getting a list of special camera properties
With this device.
These characteristics can be simple things,
Such as: any direction facing the lens,
Or something more complex such as: facial screening systems
Available.
If your app can not work without these features,
You can require the user to own
These properties are for downloading your app.
Just select the user properties in the manifest file.
It is also important to know that the Camera 2 API has been introduced
In Android L. In order to support all their applications
You will have to return to the camera API.
There is no support for the Camera API 2 in the support library
Android after, but if you spied on that person enough,
It may make support there sooner.
API Camera 2 gives you a lot of responsibility
Towards your device's cameras.
But with great responsibility comes the superpower.
I think that's how it goes.
To learn about API Camera 2 you'll lose an API reference.
If you want to see it works
A GitHub application model captures raw images.
If your app uses your camera, get the best camera experience
Using a camera 2, continued to build better applications.
[Music]